it's not good for the dallas cowboys to
not have running back ezekiel there's
been a vibe coming from the organization
now that they've gotten their their sea
legs regarding this hold out that
they'll get a deal done with ezekiel
elliott august 6 today is a day that
many have been pointing to as the
deadline for ezekiel to return in order
to get another year of credit toward
free agency i've said from the get-go
chris this day is irrelevant to ezekiel
elliot because it's not about becoming a
free agent it's about getting a contract
he's still got two more years before
he'd even be a free agent anyway this is
about drawing a line in the sand and
getting paid not setting the stage to
become a free agent he wants his money
before he's a free agent because running
backs get chewed up and spit out before
they ever get a chance to get paid on
the open market so i've said all along
this date's irrelevant i stand by it
today i'd be stunned if ezekiel elliott
says oh i better get to camp today
because i don't want to lose my year of
service toward free agency
no chance and you're a hundred percent
right mike florio i mean there's no way
he's coming to it yes you know he's he
is he's drawn the line in the sand he
doesn't give a damn if he's a free agent
or not he's trying to save his body uh
from taking more abuse until he gets
paid and i get that and this is an
underlying problem in the nfl you know
we hit on it a little during the show
but gosh young kids out there why would
you want to play running back in the nfl
right now why i mean it's just it's
crazy oh go ahead and kill yourself for
three or four years and then when it's
time to get paid and get rich we're
going to tell you you're abused and
you're damaged goods and we're not going
to pay you and you'll probably be
limping on limping later in life too and
have a lot of other physical issues but
don't worry you had a few years playing
in the nfl's running back it's bs the
nfl's got to fix it for this situation
it's the you know you've heard me say
it's the most physical position in all
of sports and yeah zeke elliott he's in
this for the long haul and uh i think
eventually he will win out and the
dallas cowboys are gonna pay him what he
deserves and what he wants
you know the the problem is at the lower
levels of the sport that the kids who
show up who are the phenomenal athletes
that's like men among boys when they get
the ball in their hands they're the ones
who become the running backs because the
coaches at those levels it's a lot
easier to win games if all you have to
do is give the ball to the best athlete
and let him go run you don't have to
worry about technique you don't have to
block you don't have to worry about
anything because nobody can catch the
guy who develops into the running back
and that carries into high school
carries into college and you get all the
fame and the notoriety because you're
the running back your your name's in the
paper you're the guy they want to
interview you're the star of the team
then you get to the nfl level and uh
you're almost as fungible as a kicker or
a punter
no
there's no there's no doubt about it uh
and you know added to that we've seen
you know
ex running backs with all the physical
issues they've had to deal with whether
it's tony dorsett or earl campbell and
the list can continue to go on and on
it's a brutal position and it's just not
fair to some of these guys it's really
not you know i always bring up alfred
morris is a perfect example he's on the
dallas cowboys roster right now to help
out the fact that ezekiel is not there
and he was a sixth round pick who was
top five in rushing in the nfl his first
few years in the nfl and you know what
happened i mean here he is fighting for
his life for the nfl minimum never got a
big payday and that's messed up and i do
think there has to be some
acknowledgement from this in the nfl to
maybe do something to where maybe the
running backs salary only counts half of
what it's really worth against the cap
something to help these guys out a
little bit because uh there's just
there's too many horror stories and not
enough adrian peterson type stories
where the guy can play for 10 and 11
years at the running back position he's
the outlier because he's one of the
greatest freaks of nature we've ever
seen in the sport
yeah the problem is most of these guys
have already given the best that they're
ever going to give during those years
where they are getting paid peanuts in
comparison to what they would get on a
second contract if they can continue to
play at a high level and not many of
them can keep that up for five six seven
eight years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports